hello everybody good morning from Keith
in an exclusive interview with President
zielinski he warned of a new Russian
offensive against Ukraine he told me
that Russian forces are building up in
the South and also the east of the
country and in an emotional message to
the parents of those soldiers he warned
nobody is meeting them with flowers it's
not their Homeland or their homes they
are dying for in a wide-ranging
interview we also spoke about his own
Journey from comedian to wartime leader
and the impact on his family life we'll
bring that to you throughout the morning
and we'll have reaction from around
Europe some of the key players including
the NATO Secretary General I sat down
with president zielinski in his office
here in Keith
Mr President there's talk of a Russian
surge coming soon
when do you think that might be and how
prepared are you
we're about
uh
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
War rips families apart a lot of young
Russian boys are being sent to their
deaths as cannon fodder what's your
message to their parents
foreign
Abram tanks are coming from the United
States and finally leopard two tanks are
coming from Europe you must be relieved
uh
um
the tanks could be here from Europe soon
but the tanks from America may take
until August is that too late too late
but but I I I don't know really I don't
know real situation for now for this
minute when they will be when they when
America uh uh will give us Abrams and
and I don't know
I don't know really when from Europe
will come tanks can I take you back to
almost a year ago and the start of the
war
is what you remember about the night
that the Russians were coming how close
were they to you some suggestions they
were just two kilometers away foreign
[Music]
if you can't sleep at night and are
alone with your thoughts do you ever
wonder what might happen if you were in
a room alone with President Putin would
that help at all to resolve this war
pretty interesting for me
for me not interesting to meet
not interesting to speak
why because we had meeting with him in
Normandy format it was before the
full-scale invasion
I saw
the man who said one thing and then did
another is it too late now
too late not interesting who is he now
after full-scale Invasion for me he is
nobody
nobody somebody who is a somebody to you
is Boris Johnson
um would you like to see him have an
official public role as a UK Envoy to
Ukraine
Embassy he will be ambassador from
Britain in Ukraine it was pleasure
I was pleasure he's a good guy and I'm
not I'm not I'm not sure that he's ready
for such status because no but who knows
I mean that Jewish pleasure was pleasure
really how would you feel if he ran
again to be prime minister would he get
your support
I think that is not correct to me to
support Johnson to be a prime minister
when
rishi's prime minister is not correct
I'm sorry we have good relations with
sunak I think we had
more long relations with Johnson because
it was more long time and of course
and of course very difficult time at the
first days of full-scale innovation
that's why I I saw Johnson in different
situations I saw him in not in war and
then in full-scale war that's why we
have special relations
we'll have more of that interview with
President zielinski throughout the
program here on Sky News and we will
play it in full at 9 30. absolutely
fascinating stuff from him including
what it's like to be a former comedian
who is now a leader of a world country
at War uh coming up in just a second
we're also going to be speaking to
Dominic wyckorn who is in Brandenburg
for us and taking you to Moscow as well
with Diana magnet to find out what the
Russians are thinking about these tanks
that have been promised for Ukraine
before all of that though Deborah Haynes
is here with me this morning hi good
morning so the president was very
pleased with his 45th birthday when will
it materialize well that's the big
question and that's why his main message
wasn't it about how it's great having
these tanks but the critical issue is
when they will arrive and in what
numbers and the reason for that is
because the offensive plans for the
offensive are happening right now and
the sooner the Ukrainian offensive
happens the better because the Russians
too are rearming you have this big
mobilization that happened in September
there was talk of potentially a second
mobilization by the Russians talk of
potentially hundreds of thousands of
Russian forces being part of a second
wave the ukrainians know that time isn't
on their side they need to act fast they
need to have credible capability which
is where these tanks come in if they're
trained on them and that takes months
potentially some have said that if you
had trained tank you've had tank
operators that are using the Ukrainian
Soviet era tanks now they could actually
be moved on to the say The British tanks
pretty quickly but for example I was
talking to a British Tanki in Estonia
last week and he was saying to me that
these these tanks they're quite old I
mean they are modern tanks compared to
Soviet era ones but they were built in
the 90s they are due an upgrade and they
do have little niggles and it really
takes time to understand the tank and
how to get the most out of it and so
that's why really getting these tanks
out here as soon as possible so that
they can be used as part of a full
offensive with artillery with other
armored vehicles to push against these
entrenched Russian positions is key that
the ukrainians will be mindful of when
the Russians are planning to attack as
well and while yes a lot of their
equipment has been depleted the Russian
industrial base is being mobilized to
ramp up production and we're just not
seeing that amongst Western allies to
the same extent and just one final point
that they were saying yesterday how this
announcement about tanks shows the
determination of the West to support
Ukraine sends that clear message to
Vladimir Putin that the West isn't going
away that they aren't just going to
leave Ukraine but the most fundamental
way they could send that message more
credibly even more credibly than the
tanks would be by ramping up that
production of artillery of ammunition to
ensure that they can they physically
have the means to support Ukraine into
the long term they also want fighter
jets now as well don't they but that
that's a conversation that is ongoing it
is well it's all about escalation I mean
it's incredible isn't it that we are
here now almost a year into this war
with main battle tanks now being agreed
you know we can both remember back in
the early days
um allies in particular Germany were
sending helmets it didn't want to send
offensive lethal weapons it's gone from
helmets to tanks in the space of 12
months there was that huge threat and it
continues to be a concern about Vladimir
Putin escalating turning this into a war
of Russia against NATO the whole of the
NATO alliance or maybe turning to the
nuclear option and clearly the Allies
have absorbed those threats have
calculated that sending tanks is not
sufficiently escalatory to be too
dangerous and who knows maybe they will
decide in time that
um even even more lethal equipment such
as fighter jets could be needed too okay
for now thanks so much indeed Deborah
thank you we're in the middle of Center
Michael's Square the biggest Square in
central Kiev this morning as you can see
a remnants of Russian tanks have been
dragged
um here as they have been deactivated as
they describe it by Ukrainian forces
it's a show of strength the show of
power not only to the world but also to
President Putin our Moscow correspondent
magnet joining us now hello to you Diana
um nevertheless the ukrainians have had
these tanks promised to them it will
take a long time for them to get here
meantime a new Russian surge on the
horizon
that's true well the ukrainians say they
expect a spring offensive from the
Russians but of course the Russians
expect the ukrainians to try and
recapture territory uh when the time is
right so I think both of them are used
are looking to see how best they can
move forward uh when conditions make it
possible I think these this tank
delivery uh will be
um viewed with concern here of course
because it does to a certain extent
change the state of play how Valerie
garasimov reacts we just don't know at
the moment but as we heard in that
interview and reading the full
transcript it's just fascinating to to
see what president zielinski had to say
about the fact that sure it's great This
Promise of Tanks but frankly it's not
the decision that matters it's when they
arrive on the battlefield Russia has
many many more tanks Russia has many
many more armored vehicles and the
ukrainians just need those tanks and
more armored vehicles more weapons in
service right now to try and recapture
some of that territory tree that they've
lost to Russia I do expect to hear more
comments from Dimitri peskov the Kremlin
spokesman when he has his daily call
today he's been asked about the tanks
for for quite a few times already
because obviously this has been
discussed a lot in Europe and I think
what will be disappointing for Moscow is
to see once again uh resolution and
unity amongst NATO members because for
the past few weeks he could point to
this dithering by Germany the lack of
Unity on the issue of Tanks as a mark of
fractures within the alliance but once
again they've actually pulled together
and I think that will be viewed with
some consternation in Moscow but again
the battle tanks fall into the Russian
narrative that this is in fact already a
war which they say nato is waging
against Russia to try and Destroy Russia
I think the comments that zielinski said
that Putin is a nobody that they only
want peace when they want to regroup
will be dismissed as well by Moscow
because always dismisses what President
zielinski says calls him simply a puppet
of the West Ukraine simply a proxy
Battleground so I don't think this
decision is going to change the
narrative that you hear from Russia but
I think there is so much in that
interview that you did Kate that's
absolutely fascinating
okay enough and I thank you very much
indeed thank you well
um is a fracture developing within NATO
yesterday I spoke to the Secretary
General Jens stoltenberg he said that
Ukraine must be prepared for a ramping
up of action by Russia this is what he
had to tell me
Russia is planning for new offensives
they are building heavily up they are
mobilized hundreds of thousands of new
troops uh ramping or production
acquiring ammunition from authoritarian
regimes like Iran uh North Korea and and
uh and therefore we have to be prepared
for a new Russian offensives
we'll bring you more of Jen
stoltenberg's reaction to my interview
with President zielinski just after
eight o'clock joined now though by
Labor's Shadow defense secretary that's
John Healy hello to Mr Healy from Kiev
this morning you heard what the Germans
what the Americans and indeed what
president zielinski has had to say about
this war in Ukraine
um is the West doing enough to help the
ukrainians
it's it's doing much of what Ukraine is
asking for this is a really important
move and decision by Germany and what's
important here is not just the tanks but
also the artillery the armored vehicles
the ammunition it was part of a big
package that Britain committed in recent
weeks the first of 2023 uh allies are
doing similar and it confronts one of
the biggest miscalculations that Putin
made by his brutal and illegal invasion
of incredible Ukraine last year which
was he miscalculated on the
determination and resolution of the the
Western countries to stand together
stand with Ukraine and to remain United
and that decision by the Germans now
about leopard tanks allows other
countries to move together to support
Ukraine in this battle to see off the
Russian aggression and reclaim their own
country
do you think that Germany's hesitancy
has damaged their reputation at all
I think if of course Ukraine would like
a lot more and it would like it
yesterday but Germany has
given a contribution to the military
assistance to Ukraine which is on a
similar scale to Britain's uh it is made
some historic moves as your
correspondent Deborah Haynes said
earlier on uh what's crucial now is that
the Western countries willing to support
Ukraine and there are more than 40
countries who are supporting Ukraine in
this battle remain United and continue
their supplies for the long term so I've
argued for many months now that the
government needs to move Beyond ad hoc
announcements as we saw last week of
Military Support to Ukraine which have
our full support but move Beyond those
ad hoc announcements to a full plan for
2023 and beyond for the military
economic humanitarian assistance will
provide to Ukraine in part because that
will give Ukraine greater confidence and
reassurance that British support will be
maintained but also it will signal to
Putin that things will get worse not
better for Russia
people and the president of Ukraine at
the moment he wants fighter jets
well Britain doesn't have any of the
F-16 Fighters that are being talked
about today in opposition we're not
party to the conversations about what
the ukrainians are asking for and on
fighter jets I note notice that this is
a debate that's been led by the
manufacturer of the fighter jets
Lockheed Martin what's most important I
think in Britain is that we now put
parts of our military procurement system
on a wartime footage so that we can
provide the ammunition and supplies not
just to continue supporting Ukraine but
to replenish our own Armed Forces stocks
and it really isn't good enough that it
took the mod
287 days to get his act together to sign
a contract to start producing the
anti-tank weapons the end laws that
we've provided in the early days of the
invasion which proves so successful and
so important and continue to be so to
Ukraine
yeah I'm not sure it's just Lockheed
Martin that are talking about fighter
jets I think you'll find that president
zoleski was pleading for them during my
interview with him uh yesterday he says
that the fight in the air could be the
way that they win this war
um against Russia we'll have to wait and
see on that a final question to you
though if I may even when labor is in
power uh what would uh what percentage
of GDP would you give to the defense
budget a three percent
the last in the last year that labor was
in power in 2010 Britain was spending
2.5 percent of our budget on defense and
that's the level the conservatives have
not got anywhere near matching in the 13
years since labor will always spend
what's required on defense what's
required on defense depends on the
assessment of the threats that's a hard
judgment to make in opposition when all
the information required to do that is
classified so that's why we've said in
year one after an election labor would
launch a Strategic Defense and Security
review it would allow us to make those
judgments and make those financial
commitments
okay it's good to speak to you this
morning thank you very much indeed for
joining us thank you thank you
thank you well
um let's turn to the next part of our
interview with President zielinski
should we um he's become a symbol of his
country's resistance of course to
Russia's Invasion he's a wartime leader
with a direct line to Downing Street and
the White House and yet he lives with a
constant threat that his own life could
be targeted so what does all that do to
your day-to-day life we find out with a
very rare glimpse of the president at
work
and you too thank you for taking the
time and giving us so much of your time
I wonder if we could walk along the
corridor and you could I noticed some of
these um pictures of
ukrainians
um Heroes yeah tell me about them yes
you know I think that
you you get to hear our veterans from
from
2014. veterans from the war in Crimea
bearing witness to the challenges the
latest conflict is having on this
battle-hardened Ukrainian regime
security is extremely tight around the
president as you would expect our
passports were checked several times
phones and laptops removed and stored
well away from president zielinski
eventually after making our way through
airport style scanners we were guided
along darkened corridors past bulging
sandbags and closed protection officers
bristling with weaponry and into these
gloomy halls
in English
sorry yeah and this is I mean this is
dark as well and what is one of the
things that strikes me
um
deficit because of Iranian attacks right
by drones
Russian attacks by Iranian entrance I
think it will be correctly but for us
the same if Russia use uses Iranian
drones it means that Iran Iran
helps that's it yes what's a normal day
like for you here how do you live your
life here that is my life now
that's how I live here yeah I mean what
do you do you do you eat at The Palace
you I mean
do you manage to go exercise here what
do you do yes I have an exercise yes
it's a very very morning early in the
morning I love to read and have some
exercise all right yes of course I wake
up yeah then get up well
six six six in the morning and love to
read if I have some time
talk me through your day briefly you you
get up you exercise
that's it work during till night and
that's it and sometimes yes bad and
sometimes you have to get up
through the night yes because of some
you know phone calls or very important
things or or decisions
um can we sit down and have a chat yes
please fantastic thank you
we wanted to know more about the
comedian turned world leader who's not
only a politician but the father of two
children one a 17 year old student and a
10 year old son who talks to his father
about events on the Battleground rather
than fun in the playground
um talk to me about your family your
family life you talked about them having
to leave just before when the war was
breaking out you see them very rarely
I I think the question is to my family
am I am I good
my like Father the attitude to me I
think it's also not
um I don't know if I can use such word
not polite to speak about me to speak me
about me in such case but I I think that
they love me
and it's not about thinking I feel it I
think these feelings is the best one and
I want to save it yes and that is the
most important I have
so my my family how often do you manage
to see them how often do you manage
often my wife than my children it's a
it's a bitter that I can see my children
you know once per
now now it's often than from the very
beginning last two three months we have
we have once per 10 days
I can see my my children one for two
weeks I can I see have some food
have some talks and I can I can see my
daughter because she's she's a student
from this year and that's why I I often
see her than my son he smoke guy
he's just young he's just young he's
he's 10 years what do you talk about
of I'm I'm I think I I I'm listening
talking he's he's he's so good he is so
sweet and and he's 10 years but he's
thinking like
a strange strategy a tragedy for all our
families I mean that through Ukraine
because all our children adults and all
of them they speak about war they speak
about when we will win they know it
exactly it's better then they know uh
better than me I think when you will win
yes they they will win tomorrow and it's
about our children and they know
everything you know about what's going
on we need tanks what the chancellor is
waiting we need we have to push we don't
have F-16 we have to push them so it's
very interesting
I I mean that but it's interesting and
from one side from Another Side like I
said to you
it's tragedy that they
they speak about it not about children's
not about their you know games between
each other not about soccer yes no no
dialogues about soccer no that is the
difference
but we will we will change this
situation I think
Deborah with us throughout the morning
here on the breakfast show live from
Kiev this morning as the snow continues
to fall it's absolutely freezing those
kids will be going to school there as
they do every day whenever they can but
he was saying they're the president they
talk about F6 students not soccer yes
and that's the kids that do go to school
you'll remember that at the beginning of
the war lots of those children and the
schools stop the country stop there was
this Nationwide loss of innocence in
that one day when these children had to
basically grow up far too quickly many
of them had to leave the kids the
children in some parts of these
countries are still doing their lessons
online if they even can have internet
and then the children here in keep and
around the parts of the countries where
it's a bit more stable yes they're going
to school but often they don't have
power they don't have heat there's the
threat of missile strikes there's been
this awful attack on the critical
infrastructure so for parents that are
here it's that constant worry every day
it's not it's just not normal life and
how awful I mean the president's living
it himself with his children and this
idea that the children aren't talking
about having fun they're talking about
whether they're going to get f-16s even
knowing what an F-16 is and then as well
to remember the children that have left
this country and their fathers um have
not left they've stayed behind and so
this has been this huge division this
separation of families all across the
world now with their fathers here in
Ukraine um fighting the war okay Deborah
um thanks so much indeed if you know
thank you well Dominic back corner
actually has just spoken to the German
defense minister and this is what he had
to say
so can you get the tanks to Ukraine in
time
of course we will how long will it take
to get there at the end of the first
quarter of the year
that's what we are going to do yeah how
many months two three four I just said
at the end of uh at the end of March I
think is that in time because ukrainians
expect a Russian offensive to be
imminent all I know is that is in time
and will there be enough there to repel
the Russian attaches so I'll bet later
what are you here for today
to see the troops and to get a picture
of what's going on here what the
soldiers are learning what they are
doing
to learn the Puma and everything else
what message do you think sending the
leopards to Ukraine sends to Vladimir
Putin then German doesn't pretend
doesn't re-lander that we stand with
Ukraine and did the hesitation was that
time lost do you think we're negotiating
and what damage was done to Germany's
reputation thank you Minister thank you
be a labor
uh Deborah that interviewed us there
with with Dominic with the German uh
defense minister Germany's come under a
lot of criticism for dragging its feet
is how it's been um described and fairly
so I mean um Chancellor Schultz that the
Hope had been that he would um agree to
these tanks much sooner than actually
happened I mean it's only it's only came
out yesterday and you'll remember last
week there was that big meeting
um in Germany where you had the the U.S
defense secretary 50 countries meeting
hoping they could have an announcement
on tanks and yet it they dragged it out
until this week and you just heard the
German defense minister speaking to our
colleague
um it's important to note he was only a
main defense minister a week ago he has
absolutely no idea about defense and
here he is in charge of this fundamental
part of the West's response to Vladimir
Putin's War
okay for now thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot
um if you are just tuning our way you're
watching um a special program a special
breakfast program live from Kiev the
Central Square here sent Michael's
square and you can see uh the Carnage of
some of the Russian vehicles that have
been taken by Ukrainian forces dragged
into this Square in central Kiev as a
demonstration uh Ukraine hopes to the
rest of the world that they are doing
what they can to win this War I sat down
yesterday actually with president
zielinski in a very rare British
interview who spoke to me in Ukrainian
and also in English and I asked him
about the war about President Putin in
particular about family life also about
his relationship with Boris Johnson as
opposed to that with uh Rishi sunak he
talked to me about tanks in Germany
tanks coming from the rest of Europe
also that promise of tanks from the
United States as well almost forgot for
a moment so this is a taste of what he
said
the tanks could be here from Europe soon
but the tanks from America may take
until August is that too late
too late
but but I I I don't know really I don't
know real situation for now for this
minute when they will be when they when
America uh will give us Abrams and and I
don't know
I don't know really where from Europe
will come tax
Mr President there's talk of a Russian
surge coming soon
when do you think that might be and how
prepared are you
um
under what circumstances would you
consider peace negotiations
[Music]
okay so let's look at which countries
have pledged modern military hardware to
Ukraine should we the United States
sending 31 M1 Abrams to Ukraine though
it could take many months for them to
get there Germany has approved the
delivery of 14 level 2 tanks
Poland has pledged 14 of those German
licensed Vehicles as well
the UK was the first country to promise
support pledging 14 of its Challenger
twos earlier this month
still no committal from France though on
its Le cloak tanks despite promises
earlier this month that they would be
the first to deliver while the
Netherlands Finland and Spain have
announced their willingness to send in
their vehicles
joined Now by General Lord Richard
dannett the former Chief of the general
staff hello to you my Lord thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
how quickly can we expect those tanks to
be in theater
well the countries that have pledged to
supply tanks will move them as quickly
as they possibly can into the area of
conflict but of course for the first
thing that's got to happen is that
Ukrainian Soldiers with some experience
of operating armored vehicles have got
to be trained now it's going to have to
be decided where that training is going
to take place because it needs to be
outside Ukraine for international
operatives to be able to maintain
consistency with their government's
policy of not putting foreign boots on
the ground in Ukraine so in the case of
the UK I would imagine we have trained
in Poland for many many years and that
is the ideal place for us to train
Ukrainian tank soldiers but the
important thing is that the principal
has now been established that Western
countries will supply uh modern Western
tanks to Ukraine and that's really
really important as your conversation
just now reported with President
zielinski he knows that he needs tanks
he needs them as quickly as possible and
he needs them to largest possible number
what impact could they have on the
course of this war
two if two effects we know from all
that's coming out of the Kremlin that
their recent mobilization has put many
tens of thousands possibly hundreds of
thousands of additional troops uh into
the front line
um and at some stage we have to assume
and president zlinski is clearly
assuming that there will be another
offensive strike uh by by the Russians
from all the evidence that we've shown
this will be a pretty low-tech offensive
yes of course they will keep up their
drone attacks but we'll see massed
artillery and we'll see Mass infantry
attacks yes they'll use whatever armor
they've got but don't forget the West
has already supplied uh huge quantities
of anti-armor weapons and have continued
to do so so I think we can have some
confidence and the ukrainians will
certainly have a high degree of
confidence that a new Russian offensive
will be blunted and will be stopped the
big question is when the ukrainians
themselves will be in a position to
mount a hopefully decisive
counter-offensive now that's clearly
going to be some time away and is going
to be dependent on when Western tanks
become available and and here is an
interesting issue okay
um I don't think for an operational
security point of view it's very helpful
if commentators in the next few weeks a
month or two commenting too much detail
on just how many tanks have been are
made available to Ukraine whether
they're when they will be available and
what they will do there must be a
building measure of operational surprise
which gives the Ukrainian High command
the opportunity to achieve surprise on
the battlefield and it'll be largely
through surprise a decisive blow and the
determination of the Ukrainian soldiers
that will break the the will and the
strength of the Russian army and that
will come at some point when that will
be is difficult to say
um but I think increasingly it's going
to become unwise to speculate about the
strength and the timing of that
Counter-Strike
okay we're talking about
um on the battlefield there of course
aren't we as I spoke to President
zielinski yesterday he was also pleading
for more missiles he was also asking for
uh fighter jets um NATO has been very
reluctant to provide
a sort of air power if you will as far
as Pilots are concerned um and that's I
suppose is because of the Optics of a
European jet shooting down a Russian
pilot
well the two issues here really and I
think there's one one of principle and
that is
we have to be consistent with the line
that we in the west are not prepared to
put uh International boots on the ground
or for that matter pilots in the air so
I think we will be consistent with that
and we will not operate with British
American German polish other Pilots uh
they're our own aircraft uh over
Ukrainian airspace but it's a separate
thing and it's akin to giving them
modern tanks the extent to which we uh
or other nations are prepared to give
the ukrainians more aircraft airframes
um it's not realistic to suggest that
Britain Germany France will will give
Ukraine any of our modern Fighters
frankly the amount of training that will
be required uh would be too much but
there are countries that still operate
uh
but many of the aircraft types that the
Ukrainian Pilots are used to operating
and that's a different issue if there
are a number of those aircrafts
available and other countries are
prepared to gift the aircraft but not
the air crew uh to Ukraine that will
increase the Ukrainian air defense and
air capability and of course if they are
at some point in the future wanting to
mount a fully integrated combined arms
attack it will involve uh tanks armored
improve fighting Vehicles self-propelled
artillery and ideally air support as
well so it's really all the question of
providing the equipment the training the
know-how to Ukraine to combine that with
their determination their will so that
they can put together an impressive
all-arms attack counter-offensive at
some point in the future when that will
be the timing of that I think that
should remain a matter of speculation
and Endeavor to cause a degree of
surprise when it comes on the Russians
okay for now thank you my Lord thank you
very much indeed there was certainly an
element of surprise here in Kiev when
the Russians almost a year ago tried
their very best to move into the City
and take over the capital of Ukraine the
night before the bars had been full uh
young people going about into clubs we
were hearing just last night about it
was it was a huge element of surprise
although it had been talked about for
weeks beforehand when it actually came
the president and his family were
actually in the presidential Palace
family taken away and ever since that
day he has been day after day after day
trying to bring this war to an end
before that before he was president it
was a comedian he was the Ukrainian
champion of Strictly Come Dancing the
voice of Paddington Bear and as I said a
comedian who earned a living by making
people laugh I spoke to him about the
transition that he's had to make and
whether he still has a sense of humor
thank you
foreign
can I ask you about your previous life
when you were an actor and a comedian
now you're a wartime leader how do you
bring that sense of humor that you
undoubtedly have
to your colleagues in order to keep up
their Spirits I I never I never lost my
sense of humor I think when people lose
it they lose up
it yeah
uh the quietness yeah
um the state of mind yeah I think so
yes you have to to concentrate and be
very serious not during monthies
you have to do it in a very important
moments in a very difficult decisions
you have to be worry you have to be
clever and you have to be adequate and
you have to be brave because you are the
leader that's it it's very important
it's not interesting what you feel you
have to do it and you have to change if
you feel that you can't you have to
change very quickly
not to run stay change and make
decisions that is very important and
very important to make decisions quicker
than enemy that is that is very
important not to think it's not about
philosophy or something like like you
know like like this you have you have to
make decisions I think that is steps to
the big victory small steps small
Victoria steps small steps each day each
day you have to you know wake up and
think what we'll do today
to make this Victory closer that is very
important and that's why but to be a
degree you have to sometimes you know
yes in the night
I have some you know 15 minutes to think
about to speak with children by phone
something like this to to to to to
not without any crying that it's so
difficult and very huge to lead the
country without all these things it's
it's not I think you will find some
people who will tell about you like in
in you know social media Etc yes without
them without it you have to be strong
and that's why humor uh sense of humor
shows
when you can joke shop sometimes of
course shows that you are okay that you
are strong that you control the
situation
it's very important to control the
uh that's it nobody can make decisions
without you
because then the result so I mean that
the result depends on you yeah so that's
why you have to concentrate and humor
makes you
human
when was the last time you laughed was
it my outfit
oh now one second ago I think last time
yeah and let me let me ask you this um
it's your birthday today yes happy
birthday it's it's not funny
I'm 45 it's not funny what would be the
best gift you could have
the best gift I don't I don't I don't
really I don't like I mean that
I had everything before my presidential
time and before this war and so I I will
not be surprised if we are speaking
about some things you know some material
materials are some material things it's
not interesting yes so
of course of course if our soldiers can
today deoccupate some little little
village it will be great because it's so
it's so difficult it's so difficult like
they go 100 meters 500 300 and then 300
back and then 500 forward so for me the
best present the best present is walking
forward that's it thank you
four spares no one not even the young
but what will be the lasting impact on
Ukraine's children of what they have
seen and what they continue to go
through joining us now is Ukrainian
consultant Child and Adolescent
psychologist Dr Dennis ugrin um hello to
you Doctor thank you for joining us on
the program this morning a special
program from Kiev for the breakfast show
what are some of the biggest challenges
that the children here in Ukraine are
going through at the moment
I would say that children in Ukraine
show amazing resilience
it's something that never ceases to
amaze me
the vast majority of children in Ukraine
will be fine
but it is important to remember that
perhaps within 20 and 30 percent of kids
affected by the war will need some
support
and there will be a small number of
young people and children who will
require quite substantial support
yeah
now
what I think is the key to
helping these kids
is that people show
um
you know a lot of
support where they are
I I have I want to say that a lot of our
children are now in Europe many are in
the UK
and the sort of
um
Humanity that the British public has
shown
is incredible it's something that
Ukraine will never ever forget
I want to say that for parents and these
kids
there are perhaps two key things that
they could do
one is to provide children with routines
it's something that parents often think
that kids need some special exciting
things when they come to new places
in fact the opposite is true kids kids
do well when they have a predictable
um lifestyle
and the other thing which is really key
to this is to allow the child to speak
about what often were really unspeakable
traumas like how at their Pace when they
are ready to do so neither forcing them
not stopping them from talking about
this
I heard from president zielinski he told
me that his ten-year-old son wants to
talk to him about F-16 Jets rather than
playing soccer in the playground at
school these kids are having to grow up
very fast kids of 10 years old should
not be talking about the impact of
fighter jets as opposed to who's won the
World Cup
oh yes children will always talk about
things that first of all adults talk
about around them
and second of all they will talk about
things that are important to them
it is tragedy that F6 teams are more
important to a lot of Ukrainian children
than whether Dynamo care is doing well
in the 10 you know in our Premiership
but it is the case I really hope that
this will not be the case for much
longer
and I'm looking forward to the times
when me and my
friends who are children in Ukraine
could talk about football as opposed to
f-16s I really hope that this time is
not far from today
okay thank you for joining us doctor we
appreciate it thank you very much indeed
so uh you've seen our interview
um with the president you can watch it
in full actually at 9 30 here on Sky
News um Deborah is with me here in the
snow in the East Central Square in Kiev
um
what was your overall take from what you
heard from him
well he this is the the the man of
um of of the moment in terms of a
wartime president with this the biggest
war in Europe since the second world war
and someone who was thrust into this
position you really brought out the you
know how he he as he sort of said
himself yourself he's a fairly new to
politics he'd been a comedian before and
yet suddenly he's the man that the world
leaders are speaking to he's having to
Galvanize
um a western uh World a western western
powers that have for far too long
um underestimated the threat posed by
Russia this country was first invaded
it's important to remember back in 2014
with the annexation of Crimea and then
that ongoing
operations by russian-backed troops in
the East and all the while Western
nations in particularly Germany and
France were trying to get the ukrainians
and the rest questions to speak to some
kind of negotiated settlement so to go
from that situation to then galvanizing
this huge effort over the past 12 months
by Western allies to send
um tank now tanks they started off with
those anti-tank weapons you remember the
British were sending in the end laws so
for German helmets to start with wasn't
there German helmets to now German tanks
but his big message I think to you was
how critical it is to keep the support
it's not about politics it's not about
saying I'm the first to send tanks here
have a few tanks it's about mass and
it's about speed because otherwise it's
completely meaningless for a country
that's going to face let's face it worth
fighting heavier fighting this year than
last year and a president a Russian
president whose ultimate goals for
Ukraine which is toppling the zelenski
government and taking back and taking
control of this country that hasn't
changed he's mobilizing more troops the
anticipation is that there will be a
second wave of the offensive maybe even
a multi-access Invasion once again as we
saw a year ago when you say that what
you mean by multi-access we're talking
about coming in from the uh East West
Eastern flank but also coming down
potentially from Belarus at the moment
we're not yes that's what we that's what
I mean but and at the moment we're not
seeing signs of that happening you'll
remember in the build up to the actual
full scale Invasion Western intelligence
had information that this was happening
it was probably one of the first Wars in
history that the other side knew
absolutely that it was coming but this
time around all that's known is the
mobilization is happening and the
rearming is happening the intent is
there and so for Ukraine they have to
not only dig in not only be prepared to
launch more offensives against these
entrenched Russian positions because
they need to get these troops out but
they absolutely need to keep galvanizing
this crucial Western support because
without the weapons it doesn't matter
how much they want to win they won't
yeah okay I know you're with us
throughout the morning Deborah for now
thanks very much indeed